welcome back a judge has ordered New
York City to reinstate all city
employees who are fired for not being
vaccinated against coven 19. and says
they should get back pay the city filed
an appeal against that ruling on Tuesday
in 2021 officials mandated that all city
employees show proof of at least one
dose of the vaccine later in the year a
private employee mandate was issued but
artist performers and athletes were
given an exemption more than a dozen
fire and sanitation workers filed a
lawsuit saying it was unfair to make an
exception for one group and not another
and the judge agreed with them the
opinion released on Monday reads in part
quote either there's a mandate for all
or there's a mandate for none the
judge's ruling also found vaccine
mandates overall to be improper but the
city's mandate will remain in place
while the case Works its way through the
appeals court
Terry the judge ruled against New York
City saying firing city employees was
arbitrary and capricious what exactly
does that mean well it means that there
was no basis for the decision to fire
some and not all I mean essentially it's
a grounds for review and if there is no
basis for how the city made that
determination then it's arbitrary and
capricious and hear what the judge is
saying is look if everyone was let go
then that's one thing but to just say
the sanitary workers aren't the ones who
are going to get paid and they're the
ones who have to be let go that's not
fair that's arbitrary so obviously it's
going to go through the Appellate
process the city is appealing we'll see
what happens there but I'm sure the city
is going to try to state that they were
making that decision based on the
evidence they had thus far as far as
scientific evidence is concerned but I
think they may lose yeah so so the city
is appealing to the highest court in New
York that what we call the court of
appeals deciding things for new work but
could this have Federal implications
with President Biden's coven mandates
well folks are certainly looking at that
right and and there would be those that
would bring claims in that regard if you
look at what the Supreme Court has done
in this regard early in this year
there's a couple of decisions one of
which prevented uh uh the vaccination
requirement for companies over a certain
size either vaccinate or test
um and then but the other one was health
care workers where it upheld actually
the requirement to vaccinate so I think
that uh they will certainly uh people of
all quarters will certainly take their
shots at the Biden mandates they
probably expect a relatively uh uh
friendly Supreme Court so perhaps rule
in their favor I don't know if they
would rule or not rule though for the
same reasons arbitrary capricious is
probably not going to happen necessarily
because there's a justification for the
vaccinations that have taken place there
are other reasons and people will take
their shots all right we'll see how that
goes both in New York and potentially
the federal level when we come back up